et maintenant voici tom villa
non non non j'espère alors tu a remplacé
guy en une fois ouais t'as une musique
d'entrée la semaine dernière tu as pas
avoir des musiques d'entrés toutes les
semaines ah bon tu repars et tu reviens
avec un café bon mais
juste pour pas que je revienne à blanc
les gréements vous pouvez le voir aller
[Musique]
un
[Applaudissements]
petit truc léger parfait les gars nous
entre noirs on se comprend alors
petits débris démission la semaine
dernière thierry bravo félicitations
semaine dernière record d'audience près
de 1 million 400 mille spectateurs fait
et même
surtout surtout avec en invité un ancien
gros une chanteuse à la retraite est un
mec avec une tache sur le nez c'était
pas gagné à la base et puis vous en ai
parlé la semaine dernière thierry de la
future réédition de mein kampf il ya
laurent ournac qui est dégoûté parce
qu'ils voulaient faire un livre sur sa
perte de poids qui voulait appeler mon
combat mais mon combat en allemand c'est
madame
très très beau plateau thierry ce soir
on a les stèles denis 1 c'est là la
seule femme de france qui est capable
d'expliquer à un hors jeu bravo non mais
c'est vrai nom mais ce qui est bien
c'est qu'avec hessel a prouvé qu'une
femme pouvait parler de foot sans dire à
chaque fin de phrase yoann gourcuff il
est trop beau et ça c'est bien c'est
vous êtes aux commandes d'une nouvelle
émission sur d8 qui s'appelle touche pas
à mon ce pauvre alors dans laquelle il y
aura une bande de chroniqueurs par
emilio il y aura raymond domenech
encore un qui a couché pour avoir du
boulot
estelle estelle denis en plus de touche
pas à mon sport sur d8 il y aura vis ma
vie sur un terrain qui va être diffusée
aussi à leur vie ma biche pas si vous
connaissez c'est cette émission qui
montre au chanteur qui devait le métier
de boucher c'est à dire le métier qui va
retourner faire concert sera terminé
[Applaudissements]
jean michel aphatie aussi après 12 ans
de bons et loyaux services sur rtl et
bien vous êtes fait remercier philippe
bouvard pourtant vous arriviez encore à
parler alors
vous avez quitté rtl pour europe 1 vous
acquitter une radio de vieux pour une
radio de d'un peu moins vieux et non non
non je rigole parce que moi aussi je
suis sur europe1 j'adore cette radio il
ya laurent cabrol ya catherine nay
michèle cotta philippe gildas jean
pierre elkabbach bon effectivement de
l'extérieur on dirait un peu la maison
de retraite du paf mais non mais c'est
là où je me rends compte que vous êtes
beaucoup trop jeune pour europe 1 en
fait les 57 en fait vous êtes arrivé dix
ans trop tôt jean michel
françois damiens je la dois vraiment et
sincèrement j'aime beaucoup françois
vous êtes originaire de bruxelles 1 ce
qui fait que vous avez un fort accent
alors l'accent belge de bruxelles en
fait c'est un mélange de hockey de
glaire
c'est une sorte d'ange in en fait voilà
et vous êtes fait connaître grâce à vos
caméras cachées alors malheureusement
vous pouvez plus en faire aujourd'hui
parce que les gens vous reconnaissent
vous avez exactement le même problème
que benjamin castaldi lui aussi peut
plus faire de télé ce que les gens le
reconnaissent
ma mission est d'amener messieurs ici
c'est de poser les questions trop con
que tirée à 10 ans n'a pas voulu vous
posez oui estelle denis estelle vous
avez déclaré quand je perds au tennis
j'ai les larmes aux yeux et quand vous
regardez les replays de ce plat de chez
vous fait quoi là
jean michel vous avez déclaré c'est un
univers où il ya du charme de
l'irrationnel et de la solitude alors
vous parliez de la politique ou de la
masturbation
françois damiens vous avez tourné de
caméras cachées encore ce qu'est ce qui
était le plus dur comprendre leur accent
rester en vie alors rester en vie
thierry je vous laisse très bon et merci
gang c'est une foule monstre station on
retrouve ici la semaine shell ou pas et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le leader
des tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu